hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the codas gambit
which derives from the scandinavian
defense which is pawnee 4
and then d5 and after the pawn takes
here one of the most common moves from
black is to play knight's f6
it's slightly more common for black to
take here with this queen but after the
queen takes knight to c3 forcing the
queen to come back white gains a tempo
so a lot of players just prefer to play
the move knight to f6 which is a great
way to continue and also think it gives
you a lot more options to play fun
openings so if they play pawn to c4 to
hold on to it you could play the
icelandic game at one of my favorite
openings in a chess with e6 here
one of the most common ways for black to
continue here is just to play the move
d4 it says hey if you want to take this
pawn here that's fine if you take with
your queen
they can still come here and play c3
forcing the queen back here if you want
to move your knight twice here to d5
that's fine as well that's definitely
worth it to give back that pawn in
material
now i have another video if you want to
look at the portuguese game but that's
if black plays bishop here to g4 but in
the coddest gambit black actually plays
the move
c6
so pawn takes here on a c6 and then
instead of taking the natural knight
takes here on c6
black's going to give up another pawn of
material and that is the move pawn to e5
now we are going to be looking at the
accepted line that's the pawn takes here
on e5 and i think it's difficult for
white to find a better move here it's
the most natural hey if black wants to
give me three ponds of material i
haven't given up any on the white side
all of a sudden this is attacking the
night here on f6 if the queens want to
come off the board if you're up in
material many times you want to just
trade down as much as material as
possible that leaves your opponent with
fewer pieces to attack so this all looks
good for white and black's going to
continue down that same path exchanging
queens here on d1
the king takes but now black's gonna
start to activate pieces
more proactively starting with the move
knight to g4
you can see the immediate threat is the
knight coming here to f2 this is forking
the king and the rook so that would be
extremely bad for white but you can also
see it's attacking this pawn here on e5
so yes
uh black is down three pawns of material
but they are now looking to attack both
of the bishops can easily get involved
into the game get activated here
so they have a lot of threats now we are
going to be looking at specifically
uh
a few options the first one is knight to
h3
this is defending this pawn here on
f2 we're also going to be looking at
what happens if the pawn just takes here
on b7 so those are the two common ones i
think you'll see the first one we'll
look at is knight two
h3 here
and then
we're going to go ahead and take with
our knight here on c6
we're still threatening this square here
on f2 and we've almost
kept this knight here on h3 from moving
it can't go anywhere because then we can
just take this piece right here and
we're also attacking this pawn here on
uh e5 with some future threats of the
knight coming here to
d4 as well
so if they want to hold on to this pawn
remember now we're only down two pawns
in material they could try something
like pawn to f4 yeah that pawn's already
under attack so you might as well
just come up here and support the
central pawn here
now black's gonna play the move bishop
here to
f5 and this does a couple things one it
attacks this c2 square which is only
being defended by the king but it also
opens up for black to play the move
king 2 c8 and castle on the queen side
getting this rook over here to d8
putting it on the same file as the king
is always going to be good now if we
kind of look at some of the the ways
that white would really want to defend
this
one of those would be okay let's go
ahead and play bishop here to d3
this is supported by the pawn here on c2
it opens up for the rook to now get
involved into the game and it does block
this file so that the king uh is no
longer immediate threats if black
decides to ca to castle we are going to
castle on the the queen side right away
so uh castle here and now it comes down
to how is white going to continue they
have a few options they could play
knight to c3 here
they could say okay we really need to
get our king off of this file so they
could play something like king 2 e2
king to e2 however
is going to be a mistake and that's
because we have the move knight to
d4
attacking the king here now where does
the king go uh the threat here that we
have is attacking this square here on c2
so they could decide let's go ahead and
play king to d2 to try to hold on to
this but we can actually just take right
here they can't take with their bishop
because that's being pinned down by the
rook here on d8
but if they take with their king here we
can actually just take with our rook on
d3
and now they are in a really tough spot
you can see the king cannot move all the
squares are being attacked by the rook
here so it's stuck and then as soon as
the rook moves there's going to be a
discovered check with the bishop here on
f5 so
that's some logical moves that white may
go down but all of them are going to
result in a very very easy victory for
black
let's come back a few moves and instead
of
playing king 2 d2 because we recognize
that's not going to end well maybe they
play king 2 e1 okay well now we're just
going to take the bishop here on d3 and
as soon as the pawn comes here to a d3
we could play knight to c2 this is
forking the rook here on a1 it's going
to fall but even if they don't have
their king here on e1
maybe they recognize that's going to be
a bad spot so they come back here to
king to f1
it doesn't really help anything because
bishop takes pawn exchanges here and
then knight to c2 it's no longer check
but the rook is still trapped and now
the king here on f1 is blocking the rook
here on h1 so all in all this is going
to be a pretty tough spot for them to be
in so if we look at it and say hey the
king coming here to e2 getting off this
d file
seems logical but you can tell there's
just so many threats that black has
there's no way for them to stop after
the knight comes up here to d4 so that
is not going to work another option that
they have is knight coming here to
c3
now from here i like black playing the
move pawn to f6 and the the first time
you look at us like man there are so
many other threats how do you play
pawn to f6 and really the thought is
that after the pawn takes here we take
with our pawn here on f6 and this does a
few things but one of the things it does
is it stops this knight here on h3 yes
black is still down a little bit in
material but this knight we already
talked about can't come to f2 because
that's being attacked by the knight here
on at g4 so this knight has a lot of
threats it's attacking this square here
on f2 but it also eventually is
attacking the square here on e3 so it's
keeping this dark square bishop from
really getting involved into the game
and you can see now the knight here on
h3 it would like to come to g5 but this
pawn here on f6 is really stopping that
this also opens up the door for the dark
square bishop if it wanted to come here
to h6 but many times it's just going to
come over here to b4 where i think the
most logical place for it is going to be
coming here to c5
just centralizing it just attacking as
many central squares as possible so i
think c5 makes a lot of sense and then
black can even swing the other recover
to the e-file
and really attack on that front as
well so if we come back a few more moves
after we take the pawn here on c6 with
knight to c6 we looked at let's say they
play pawn to f4 now they could try to
protect this with another move let's say
bishop to
b4
that gets another piece involved into
the game so things are going to be
slightly different if we look at the
same things that we did before so bishop
here to f5
attacking the c2 square preparing to
castle on the queen side maybe they
still do the same thing with bishop here
to d3 we castle on the queen side they
play king here 2e2 we play knight 2 d4
king d2 again not the best moves but
want to show you how this slight change
with the bishop coming out would change
things for white's perspective now we
take here on c2 they take here but after
the rook takes on d3 they have the move
king 2
c1 they're still in a really tough spot
don't get me wrong because now we play
bishop here to c5 and we just have so
much more material involved into the
game remember they have the knight here
on h3 uh we eventually may still want to
play our f6 and then take here so they
can't come over here to g5 and threaten
rf7 square but you can see the rook here
on a1 is not going anywhere anywhere
very easy for us to bring our rook over
here to d8 and attack but this is how
it's going to be different if that
bishop comes here to f4 instead of the
pawn coming here
the last thing we're going to look at is
if the pawn takes here on b7 now i think
this is the better play for white
although many players i think when they
analyze this they might feel
like pawn taking here on b7 is a bad
move because
bishop takes here on b7
and now
black has a lot of threats this bishop
here on b7 is eyeing down this long
light square diagonal here and so they
may say oh my goodness i just allowed my
opponent to gain a tempo here
and now attack a lot of the critical
squares on the board
so they may decide hey i'm already up in
material i don't think i should go ahead
and trade off the pawns here on b7 i
actually do think it is the better play
for white
so now they still have to worry about
the move knight takes here on f2 that's
not going away even if they decide to
exchange here on b7 so i still think
knight two h3 is still a very logical
play
uh for them to make you know if they
want to play something like bishop here
to e3
exchange off some material they can do
that we can also just take the pawn here
on e5 so we have a lot of options we can
get our dark scrub bishop involved into
the game knight here to c6 as well makes
a lot of sense so we can go ahead and
castle on the queen side but knight to
h3 i think is gonna be a very logical
play that you'll see
knight to c6 the main difference is
you know on the previous variations we
were bringing our bishop here to f5
that's not going to be the case because
the bishop here is on b7 but that does
not matter when it comes to castling so
if they still play the pawn to f4 we're
still gonna castle on the queen side we
have a lot of similar threats as before
the main difference that you'll see now
is i don't think white's going to play
bishop here to d3
because our bishop's not here on f5 i
mean they could but i don't think they
will i think they're more inclined to
play something like bishop here to d2
and if that's the case we can still play
knight to d4 but it's for a different
reason now this is opening up for the
light square bishop to attack
the other time we were doing it is to
actually attack the king which sometimes
could have come to e2 if the king does
come to e2 yes we're still going to be
playing knight to d4 to check the king
which i think would be an ultra bad move
from from white but just want to give
you an idea of some of the stuff you
should be looking out for uh in this
opening so maybe they play knight to c3
here we can get our dark square bishop
involved into the game bring our rook
over here we can obviously play the pawn
to f6 at some point exchange here so we
can block off the knight coming here to
uh jeff's g5 so a lot of the same
principles that you've seen
earlier in the video are going to apply
even if they take that pawn here on b7
so that is
the goddess gambit hopefully you guys
enjoy this
the scandinavian defense has a lot of
fun gambits to play so hopefully you can
add this into your repertoire if you
like to play
d5 when you face e4 thank you guys so
much for watching the video if you
haven't already hit the subscribe hit
the like button and then comment below
let me know what you guys thought of
this
video if there's others you want me to
to make feel free to let me know that as
well always looking for ideas for new
videos but thank you so much for
watching the video i appreciate the
support i'll see you guys next time